Germany have been world champions four
times no less but they've come to Qatar
with a point to prove after finishing
bottom of their group in Russia four
years ago
they had wanted to wear the one love
Captain's armband but like England and
Wales were banned by FIFA they have
threatened to take the decision to court
we need some Freedom you understand and
everybody loves everybody do you think
the players the captains should wear the
armband no why not
that doesn't mean anything I believe in
the rights but it has to be to them not
Sports has to be sport before the game
started the German side made their
feelings clear posing for the
pre-matched photo the players covered
their mouths to show their being
silenced a tweet explained why it
wearing the armband that is wasn't about
making a political statement they said
human rights are non-negotiable that
should be taken for granted but it still
isn't the case that's why this message
is so important to us denying us the
armband is the same as denying us a
voice We Stand by our position
the German interior Minister was at the
game and she wore the one love armband
sat next to the FIFA president Gianni
Infantino in today's times it's
completely incomprehensible that FIFA
does not want people to openly stand up
for tolerance and against discrimination
Japan are no pushover eight of their
squad play in the German Bundesliga and
two in the Premier League but the first
half went the way of the European
Powerhouse just after the half hour mark
Germany were awarded a penalty when
David Ram was brought down by the
Japanese keeper man City's ilkai gundwan
put the spot kick down the middle to
give his side the lead the Germans don't
miss many penalties it was end-to-end
stuff and in the second half Japan came
back with 75 minutes gone Manuel Neuer
spilled it and ritzu Doan just on as a
substitute had an easy finish then with
seven minutes of normal time to go a
long ball over the top beat the German
defense it was controlled Inside the Box
by takumarasanu and buried into the roof
of the net to give Japan a shock lead
Japan held on to a deserved and first
win ever over Germany Germany are now
under real pressure to qualify for the
next round next up they face Spain on
Sunday this world cup is not going to
plan on or off the pitch alistabunga Sky
News in Qatar